look there is no federal solution this
gets solved at a state level i'm looking
at governor sununu on the board here he
talks about that a lot
and it ultimately gets down to
where the rubber meets the road and
that's where the patient is in need of
help or preventing the need for help
that's president biden last week saying
the solution to fighting covet 19
resides at the state level despite his
promise to quote shut down the virus
during the 2020 presidential campaign
this comes as new cases are rapidly
surging across the country due to the
omicron variant new york set a record
yesterday for its highest ever single
day total of new cases with over 85 000.
florida is also seeing record high cases
meanwhile the biden administration has
promised to deliver
500 million at-home tests soon
despite the administration reportedly
rejecting a proposal from testing
experts in october to ramp up production
before the holidays the president has
denied that report for more on this
let's bring in new york congresswoman
nicole malliotakis she's a member of the
house transportation and infrastructure
committee congresswoman thank you so
much for joining us on sunday morning
futures look the president has been all
over the map he promised to shut it down
in july he said essentially it was shut
down now he's saying it's really up to
the states he said he had a plan but i i
can't tell if the guy has a plan because
if it is he's holding a really good
secret there
well happy new year jason thank you for
having me the reality is that the
president made a lot of promises during
the campaign trail we're not seeing it
come to fruition
now in fact he was so critical of
president trump yet we've had more
deaths in 2021 under president biden and
he had the benefit of the vaccination
which we know reduces the symptoms that
somebody experiences if they test
positive and i can tell you from a state
like new york where we have one party
rule and we see restrictions and
mandates and people being fired losing
their livelihood if they choose not to
vaccinate
these restrictions have done nothing to
really reduce the level of these
positive cases as you said earlier we're
seeing record positive cases once again
and i believe it's time that these this
administration focus on therapeutics
focus on treatments and i've been
pushing for that because the reality is
is that this virus is here to stay it's
various variants various forms but we
need to learn to live with it and the
best we're going to do
by both vaccinating people who want to
be vaccinated and making sure they have
access to it but also ensuring that we
have the therapeutics and the treatment
to treat people including those positive
patients that do end up getting sick
even despite having the vaccination
yeah i i kind of like what uh
congressman uh jim jordan said he said
if president biden's plan is working
how come it's not working um you know it
just begs the question you have people
now that are saying the wrong
way to track this is by the number of
new cases how convenient for the new
president uh to be able to take on on
this role but it also strikes me
congresswoman that it is not a very
targeted approach to just blanketly send
out 500 million tests why not target
those that are the most vulnerable why
not target the people that actually are
showing symptoms i just don't understand
why that isn't the prevailing thought
there in washington d.c
i i agree with you and this
administration sally has been just very
reactive so instead of focusing on the
treatments and therapeutics they want to
focus on more mandates and you're right
if if he believes now this should be the
responsibility of the states why is he
continuing to try to enforce this
mandate on every business across america
82 million americans would be affected
by it and many will lose their
livelihoods as a result that is why i
and 180 other
colleagues of mine in congress have
filed an amicus brief with the supreme
court which will be hearing that case uh
or at least for the stay on january 7th
well uh good luck with that um i want to
talk about crime because there is an
intersection here and i know you're keen
on crime and being able to fight crime
first of all we have an open border it's
as porous as it can be it just flows
people coming across with with who knows
what whether it's omicron or or you know
the the virus or drugs or whatnot but
then you also have this crime surge
that's happening in these democratic
cities including new york city which is
close to you
yeah one of the first things i did as a
member of congress was visit the
southern border to expose what was going
on there and basically president biden
has allowed the drug cartels to run our
southern border we are seeing record
individuals being smuggled over the
border but also we're seeing drugs
fentanyl as you know is now the leading
cause of deaths in a new report among 18
to 45 year olds so we could talk about
covid but among that age group it is
fentanyl and that stuff is pouring over
our border the drug cartels are making
billions and billions of dollars
a month just doing that and so we we
need to
secure our border it is shocking to me
that president biden continues to push
the supreme court to allow him to repeal
once again the remain in order he
doesn't want to comply with it despite
the fact that it was effective in
keeping people in mexico could contin
until their asylum cases can be heard
and it's they're properly vetted now
locally we have new york city of course
is sadly a sanctuary city we continue to
protect those who are here illegally
committing crimes in fact someone who
was arrested a mexican national who was
committing drug uh trafficking allegedly
fentanyl here in new york city was
released by a judge back onto the
streets so we need our mayor to appoint
good judges to the bench number one
but we also need to ensure that he
fights for changes to the disastrous
bail reform in albany that has led to
individuals constantly being put on back
on the streets despite having dozen two
dozen three dozen prior arrests and
convictions
unfortunately in new york city in 2021
we saw five nearly 500 murders which is
uh the most we've seen in a decade here
in new york city and categories of crime
everything from shootings to rape to
robbery to car thefts have all
skyrocketed in fact be interesting to
know that alexandria casio cortez's home
borough of the bronx is where a third of
the shootings took place in new york
city and she is one of the leading
advocates of the defund the police
movement
yeah this idea of the bail reform
getting these people back out on the
street as quickly as possible i think is
is not the right uh way to solve this
and you have to have prosecutors that
are actually going to prosecute these
crimes in los angeles with
the district attorney gascon you've seen
it as as rampant as can possibly be and
the solution ends up just being just
absolutely horrendous in terms of its of
its uh of its consequences i want to
turn out let's uh let's listen to
governor abbott he was interviewed by
maria bartoromo and i want you to listen
this and give me your reaction to it
the cartels are advertising on tick-tock
to get drivers to assist and them moving
illegal immigrants around the state of
texas it's an issue that the texas
department of public safety is working
to crack down upon but it shows the
extent to which texas law enforcement
officers have to step up and deal with
the challenges that are created by the
by demonstration importing illegal
activity into our country and into our
state
now we we only have a short amount of
time here but i think we've been you've
been talking about this the crime covid
fentanyl open borders they all kind of
mesh together but you're left with
states like like texas where governor
abbott has got his hands full and the
administration is not doing its job what
can you do in congress to get to get the
administration to actually enforce the
laws that are currently on the books
well as you know those states have taken
their fight to court which is the right
thing to do and that is why the bind
administration has been forced to
reinstate the remain in mexico the sad
thing is is that now they're even
fighting to try to get the supreme court
to revisit it again so they can no
longer enforce the remaining mexico
policy that was clear and was working
the reality is and this is what i asked
on the floor
to my colleagues and the president of
the united states whose side are you on
are you on the side of the drug cartels
or you're on the side of the american
people when you see those numbers out of
18 to 45 year olds the leading cause of
death is fentanyl you know it's
streaming over our border you have a
responsibility to do something and the
fact that they go out of their way to
continue to allow this illegal migration
which by the way this year will total
more than the population of the
president's home state of delaware and
the the the vice president's home city
of san francisco combined so we have
legislation that would permanently put
remain in mexico into law but we need to
take back the house in order to do it
because nancy pelosi would never allow
it to the floor under this congress
yeah there are 23 retiring democrats uh
on slate here and uh republicans better
come up with a way to not just be the
party of no but just and say hey this is
our agenda this is what we would do this
if you put us in charge is what we will
actually do because all of these
retirements these wave of retirements
creates a great opportunity and uh
republicans we're going to have to have
you back on talk more about their agenda
what they can do but for now let's just
say
happy new year and thank you
congresswoman maliatakas thank you for
joining us here on sunday morning
futures
happy new year thank you